I just got in a PR box from Merit Beauty
so let's do a transitional fall look using merit products
okay first of all
this is the first PR box I've gotten that came
look at this little like
corduroy satchel oh
so excited okay
what was in the box we have the three blush combo
this is the mini Flush Bomb trio
I already have one of these balms and I absolutely love the formula
so I'm really excited to try these out
and this is called their dress code set
this is three fall shades of lip color for the season
so I'm gonna do my base and then we're gonna check these out
now these are the colors that you get in this set
this is mood which is like this almost like Berry colour
beautiful
Stockholm which has a little bit of orange to it
it's like this nice dusty rose
and then this is bespoke it looks brown in the container
but I'm excited to see what it'll look like on the skin
I think I'm gonna go with the mood flush bomb today just to see
because I've never really used a Berry coloured
ooh
okay now you can see these are super pigmented
so let's blend them out and I'm just gonna use my finger honestly
cause they blend so nicely
that's what I really like about the other color I have
is these just melt into the skin
just gonna set with a little bit of powder
so pretty I love that
now I also have three lip colors to choose from
this is black tie bespoke
and dijour I'm gonna take them out so you can see the colors
black tie
bespoke
ooh dijour
this is like a really pretty mauve
I think I'm gonna try this one
already super creamy
and this is a matte color
so I'm shocked that it's this creamy
holy cow okay
so this is the creamiest matte color
it almost has this like
powdery effect but this is such a subtle shade
I'm kind of obsessed with this
wow okay
I actually wanna try the other ones
cause now I'm I'm intrigued this is black tie
oh yeah okay
I'm a sucker for a red lip
and this is so subtle it's almost that like
burgundy just kissed after drinking red wine look
it is fabulous and this is the last one this is bespoke
oh this one's luminous
so that felt like Chapstick going on
so it feels almost like I'm not wearing anything
but the color is this like
beautiful coffee red it's like
it's got brown undertones
it's very luminous you can see the shine
um and really lightweight
ooh this is a really good everyday
like lip for the fall
but I'm gonna go with black tie today
you can find the link to Merit Beauty
and all of their fall collection makeup in the link in my bio